we're gonna take you back to Baghdad now
in our breaking news story
thousands of anti-american protesters
are gathered outside the US Embassy in
the Iraqi capital and we're trying to
force their way in CBS News foreign
correspondent Holly Williams is
following this developing story and
joining us now from Istanbul so Holly
what do we know so far what is going on
well thousands of protesters moved
through the supposedly high-security
Green Zone in Baghdad this morning an
area guarded by Iraqi security forces
and right up to the perimeter of the
u.s. embassy compound we've seen images
that show them setting fire to the fence
pulling down embassy signs and smashing
the glass of a security box that they
also set on fire there are reports of
tear gas canisters being fired and
security cameras being dismantled video
showed the protesters chanting god is
great
America is the greatest devil and down
with the USA this violent demonstration
is a reaction to American airstrikes on
Sunday targeting a militia group in Iraq
that is backed by Iran those u.s.
strikes killed at least 25 militia
fighters the American strikes were in
turn an act of retaliation for the
killing of a US citizen last week an
American contractor working on an Iraqi
military base who died in a rocket
attack there are currently around five
thousand US troops in Iraq and here is
the bigger picture the u.s. and Iran are
vying for influence in Iraq a country
that is fractured and inured to
bloodshed nearly 17 years after the US
invasion those tensions are ratcheting
up and there are fears that they could
spiral into a full-blown proxy war
between the u.s. and Iran fought inside
Iraq and Murray so are we hearing from
the US how's the us responding well
there were reports earlier today that
the u.s. embassy compound had been
evacuated we do not think that those
reports are true at the very least we
cannot confirm them there are US troops
inside the embassy compound which is
sprawling it's absolutely enormous
within the green zone however as far as
we know so so far they haven't taken any
action
and presumably they will very much be
hoping that they can rely on the Iraqi
security forces to protect the compound
because if the US troops do get involved
that would run the risk of inflaming
things further so are there any steps
then being taken towards some sort of a
resolution or is it just sort of a watch
and see how things develop approach well
we have had a statement from the Iraqi
caretaker Prime Minister this morning
now he condemned the US airstrikes on
Sunday and called the militia fighters
who were killed martyrs but he also
called on the protesters to leave the
embassy alone not to target embassies
within Baghdad however it's not clear
how much impact that will have how
likely it is to deter the protesters
given that there are several quite
powerful political figures within Iraq
that seems to be taking part in these
protests all right Holly thank you so
much for bringing us up to speed